what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to talk about
a hate comment yep i hate comment that i
got on one of my videos
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified
of my daily videos okay
so the reason i'm going to be bringing
up this hate comment
is because i actually agreed with it a
little bit um
i always said that i would i've made it
when i start getting hate comments on
the internet
so today's that day i guess so
the comment was left on the interview i
did with
shishazad oh my god i hope i said his
name right i've avoided saying his name
with him
because i don't know how to say it but
um i hope he doesn't see this
don't guys don't no one says him um
but anyways it said that female tomboys
are the male equivalent of sims
and or the female equivalent of sims
and that i defend being a tomboy so i'm
gonna tell you why i thought this was
funny i have never been
the type to have a ton of guy friends um
i mean i'm not gonna say i've had none
um i've maybe had one or two but for
every like one guy friend i've had i
have at least
three female friends like it is not even
close i'm not one of those girls that
says guys are less drama
no i mean i'm kind of emotional i like
talking to girls about emotions
um but i thought it was a really
interesting point like
tomboys like girls that are just one of
the guys sleep with the whole friend
group
and just say like i hang out with boys
because they're less drama
that is totally the female version or
the female version of a simp
that totally is because
they give away sex like for free
basically and like the same way
guys give away the attention for free
you know does that make sense
so i totally i actually sort of agreed
with that part of the comments second
part he said
was that i defend being a tomboy i'm
gonna
i'm just gonna make this very clear i do
not encourage women to be tomboys
um i would totally agree that if i was
you know 100 after male attention like
that was my goal
i would definitely get more um if i was
super girly
um but here's the thing like when you're
looking for a partner and you're looking
for a husband
i'm not gonna pretend to be something
i'm not and
i'm not the type of girl that's gonna
spend a ton of money on clothes
spend a lot of time learning how to do
makeup and hair
um i have no problem like dressing up
every now and then but
it's just not me and
yeah it's just it's not who i am i'm the
type of girl i love sports i love to
play basketball
um yeah that's just not me
so i don't encourage women especially
like for dating to be more tomboyish
i just don't pretend to be something
you're not and sometimes in the
manosphere
i think they encourage um
so they they think that above everything
else you should just
be trying to get a partner um so like in
this case he would say that i should be
less tomboyish
in order to attract a partner and
i don't know sometimes i think there's
some value in being who you
are and loving yourself obviously you
know
to an extent right but i don't know i'm
just not the type
to pretend to be something i'm not so
anyways it was just
that comment was like thought-provoking
i wasn't really offended i just really
thought it was interesting so
let me know in the comments if you guys
think that a
female tomboy um
one of the guys is the female
club equivalent of ascent because i do
actually i really do that makes a lot of
sense
i will talk to you guys next time